[Music]
yeah uh kendall i have logan for you
we're holding on the tarmac yeah hey so
look i think it's pretty obvious what we
need to say so i'm headed straight to
josh's compound
tell dad meet me
it's from roadrunner
we were all fascinated in the writer's
room by having this opportunity to see
what it would be like when kendall and
logan first meet
so
it seemed like they would only do that
under very particular circumstances
hello son hey dad
some very uncomfortable common ground
between kendall and logan's which is for
today they need to do the business
they need to convince this one man and
the strain of that is almost unbearable
but it's true for them both
jesse has a way of writing the unspoken
that silence felt true
i think it's just too much too much to
say
they're running a multi-billion dollar
empire logan knows he has to do a dance
for josh i guess i have concerns can we
take a walk
because josh is very important he's a
major shareholder and we don't want to
lose him logan i think he's a
compartmentalizer so i'm not sure it
hurts him that much to turn on his
available charm which a lot of these
powerful guys they have some of that in
the locker
as long as the dance is quite formalized
and ritualized i don't think it costs
you too much to be involved but maybe he
gets pushed a little further than he'd
like by josh end of the day you work for
the shareholders for me
as long as he's asked for something he
can't give when is this gonna end
i don't like betting on blood feuds
my father is the gravitational force of
my life either in relation to him or in
opposition to him
jesse has tracked that relationship very
differently in each season we've reached
a point where logan does love his son he
does think his son is extraordinarily
talented it'll be okay because he's a
good kid and i love him
okay
maybe he's the best one of all and i
think he means it
my father there's a sense that he's
proud of what i've done but i'm trying
to be past that because i've seen what
he is
nice speeches
yeah
well he'll say they're gonna get [ __ ]
on her date okay
all our relationships to our parents are
complicated and boy are they complicated
in this family
does kendall hate logan yeah does he
love him yeah yeah and there's a lot
more layers below that to unpick i put
you in the ground that day and you don't
get to come back
face it son
you lost
you